hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 19 video canary cry
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet they did a whole bunch of
comic-book stuff that's gonna go into
season 5 usually when episodes air I'm
live tweeting so I saw a bunch of people
complaining about the flash spoiler at
the end of the episode because they're
just they always have problems with
continuity between the shows because
their production schedules so even
though Barry did not have his powers on
the flash this week he has powers at the
end of this episode so you're like oh
well clearly we were meant to see next
week's episode of the flash before we
saw this week's episode of arrow and
it's a little bit wonky but you get the
idea at least you know what they're
going for but Evelyn Crawford is the new
character that they introduced from the
comics on the TV show her name is Evelyn
sharp but if you guys have been watching
the last couple seasons even on the
flash and any comic book show for that
matter they always change the names in
subtle ways just because it's not gonna
be an exact carbon copy of the character
from the comics but Evelyn Crawford was
part of birds of prey swamp totally
explain her character and what's going
on with the new Black Canary as we go
through top five so number five meet
Evelyn Crawford Evelyn sharp on the show
we'll just call her Evelyn for now or
you can call her Black Canary because
that's basically what's going on she's
gonna take the mantle so it's not like
they completely fridge the Black Canary
even though they kind of fridge DeLauro
character I feel like after they killed
Laurel there were like two or three
different reasons people were really
upset with the show one because there
was a group of people that really liked
Katie Cassidy on the show they're like
oh you're killing her off we're so upset
with you the second group were really
mad because they felt like they were
killing Laurel off so that Oliver could
get married to felicity it's like you
know one of those crazy shipping things
Marc Guggenheim already explained that
that's not what they're doing they're
not killing laurels character to promote
felicity but the third reason I feel
like people were really mad and I feel
like this is the biggest reason is
because they felt like they were getting
rid of the Black Canary character
completely like this was going to be the
only version of her
and those people like how can there be
green arrow without Black Canary they
have such a history in the comics so
yeah the TV shows different but they're
not fridging the Black Canary there will
totally be a Black Canary but they're
passing the mantle on to a different
character so you know even if you're not
totally satisfied with that at least be
happy with the idea that there will be
Black Canary on arrow going forward so
who the hell is Evelyn Crawford well she
was a care
that they introduced during the new 52
runner birds of prey she was written
into the continuity as an old friend of
laurels and took the name Starling so I
you know I like the idea that you have a
character from the comics name Starling
on the TV show in a city that used to be
called Starling city but now the city on
arrow is called star City they rebranded
the city you can see the way she's
characterizing the comics in the way
this episode presented her she's kind of
like a more metal version of the Black
Canary she's dropping bodies like season
1 Oliver she really was like season 1
Oliver in this episode which is why at
the end of the episode when Oliver
stopped her from killing Ruby Adams he
was like yeah I've seen this before and
just like jetted away like he was having
a flashback to Quentin Lance going after
him we got to get that vigilante we got
to lock him up so number 4 WTF is that
you've basically met the new Black
Canary I don't know how much more she's
gonna be in this season maybe a little
bit because they've already got so much
that they have to wrap up with this
damian darhk-- plotline i think they'll
spend most of the first half of season 5
developing the Evelyn's character but is
there anybody here who does not expect
her to become a part of team arrow
eventually the whole thing with her in
the episode is that she wants revenge
for what happened to her family she
wants justice you can totally see the
direction they're gonna go with this
Oliver being one of the few characters
that hasn't gone off the rails Diggle
style I'm really excited about that
we'll talk about that in a second is
gonna go to her and say look if you want
to honor your family's legacy if you
want to honor laurels legacy and be this
sixteen-year-old badass vigilante you
need to work with us I can train you to
be better I can train you to do it the
right way so that's gonna take some time
I'm not expecting it to happen right
away
although arrow just totally rolled into
this super fast a minute she showed up
in the episode I actually thought it was
a Laurel flashback just because you know
they ran through it so quickly but then
when they're like oh the wig is missing
in the canary cry has been modified - I
was like wow this is fast the writers
had teased that they might be able to
pass the Black Canary mantle on
eventually but I felt like that was
something they were gonna keep in their
back pocket for a while but just because
she's wearing the costume and she's got
the canary cry and she's a badass
doesn't mean they're gonna start calling
her the Black Canary right away but
there were a couple lines of dialogue in
the episode where they were like well
she might not be the Black Canary Laurel
is the Black Canary but the world is
going to brand this girl pin all these
crimes on her as the Black Canary so
whether she is or she isn't people will
be calling her the Black Canary so
that's why number two WTF at the funeral
Oliver alt Laurel as the Black Canary
she wasn't at that prison as Laurel
Lance she was there because she's the
Black Canary I mean it was a really
great speech honoring her memory but in
addition to you know trying to make you
cry a little bit it's also intended to
get out in front of this smear campaign
that Roubaix Adams is trying to run
she's basically you know number one WTF
doing a version of what Quentin did
during season one and season two when he
was running the anti-vigilante task
force it's almost like history's
repeating itself a little like Oliver
said I've seen this one before so now he
knows how to better handle this on the
flip side he has absolutely no idea how
to handle damien darhk's magic so maybe
there'll be some hat tips to Constantine
because he when he's talking to felicity
here he's talking about fighting
darkness now he's talking about
metaphorical darkness like Diggle is
going dark I don't know who I am anymore
that should actually be my number one
WTF to Diggle going off the rails that's
gonna continue to be a big thing and I
will say the title of the finale is
schism as in you know schism and team
arrow maybe so Diggle is totally going
off the rails Oliver doesn't want to do
that so he has to find a solution to
fight damien darhk's magic that won't
also twist him up inside - but let me
know in the comments what do you think
about the new Black Canary and which
episode do you think that she will start
to work with team arrow in do you think
it's gonna be like the first half of
season 5 do you think she'll be fighting
with team arrow before this season
finale she's got to come back at least
once or twice before the season finale
this season even if it's only gonna be
set up for what she does in season 5 but
I'm really excited you can kind of see
what they're doing they want a more
metal version of Black Canary we want to
bring back some of that Oliver season 1
energy
he was just like an animal and we want
to give that to another character even
though Thea's kind of been animal-like
but she's moved past it so super metal
super angry Black Canary coming to the
show in season 5 but I should also say I
didn't say this in her backstory they
say that she's bisexual in the comics I
don't know if she's gonna be bisexual on
the TV show they've had a little bit of
fun with that with like Sarah and mrs.
character but it's way too early to know
about that giveaway reminder though I
almost forgot there's a new round of the
DC giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video there'll be a couple other
DC videos that I post this week
just remind everyone about the giveaway
I'll announce the winner whenever I post
my last one I have a Killing Joke video
that I'm working on there's a new
legends of tomorrow episode maybe some
new Suicide Squad and don't forget
Captain America is dropping in theaters
next week while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for last night's episode of the flash
and you can click here for my spider-man
Civil War video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight